with transits being the predominant
method of exoplanet Discovery what can
you identify using this method measuring
the atmosphere of the planet and the
elements or molecules in the atmosphere
so what you can do is you take a
spectrum of the star when the planet is
not in front of it so you take a
spectrum you see the Starlight split
into wavelength from that you can figure
out what elements there are in the
spectrum of that star and then you take
another one when the planet is blocking
the star and the Starlight is actually
shining through the atmosphere of the
planet and the planet's atmosphere will
be absorbing some of the Starlight if
you compare the two you can tell what
the atmosphere of the planet is made of
wow and I think it's you know you can
tell okay there is an atmosphere here
which has water molecules in it or it
has sodium in it or if it has oxygen
that'd be kind of interesting because
oxygen is not stable and so something
would be making that oxygen this would
be your first indication release your
first hint of life